ruslan let me ask you um
because you're like our local
um
expert on christianity
in studio expert is there a difference
between being
a porn star a stripper an only fans girl
like in the eyes of the lord
how you know
i think i i saw some stat that 50
percent of christians watch porn
something like that some crazy stuff i
can pull it up yeah
but
i think part of the problem i have with
like
christianity or even the like
uh televangelist is like the judgment i
feel like it's very judgey yeah that's
just me
but
she's a freaking nurse she saves lives
good mom good good you know good wife
she happens to have sex on camera with
her husband it's a friend and makes a
lot of money
um give me the good bad and ugly of what
you're hearing because it's not all good
it's not all bad it's not all ugly well
first of all you guys found the most
conservative only fans motto
she's like yeah
not to do it like oh you didn't say that
but yeah it was it was i think there was
a lot of wisdom in which you did say
uh to that to that specific mindset so
obviously there's a spectrum
i think if we're talking in the eyes
of what again the standard is
according to the scriptures i think
there's a standard there in terms of
what is the human body designed for
and we
usually revert to one of three things
lust of the eyes lust of the flesh pride
of life so that tends to be the things
that sell the easiest say those three
things again lust of the eyes lust of
the flesh the pride of life so the lust
of the eyes is sex lust of the flesh is
i want to feel good dopamine
you know food drugs and pride of life i
want to feel like i'm the man right so
so
those types of whatever content that's
that reinforces one of those three
things
is usually going to be the stuff that
pops off
and so
um
you know i i love
first corinthians chapter five and if
you guys have ever read the book of
first corinthians it's one of the
earliest books written in the new
testament paul's writing this church in
corinth and this is
about a decade after jesus resurrects
and he's writing this church so churches
are growing all over and there's this
church and paul's writing them and he's
like
man like chapter one you guys are doing
great i keep going chapter two it's like
yeah you know i'm glad i didn't baptize
any of you because some of you guys are
kind of weird chapter three man you guys
are pretty carnal and acting pretty
fleshly chapter five boom jerry springer
bombshell there's a you guys are doing
something that not even the pagans do
yeah a dude in the church
has his father's wife
and you're okay with it and you're
celebrating it okay so anyone that's
like america's going to hell
chapter 5 and first corinthians that's
the homework right
gnarly stuff so this dude is either
smashing his stepmom or smashing his bio
mom and the church in corinth knows
about it and not only they know about it
he must have been of some stature or
celebrity they were okay with it they
were he was still celebrated and paul
goes on to tell him and he says listen i
told you in my previous book not to
associate with people that were sexually
immoral i wasn't talking about people
who aren't christians i wasn't talking
about people in the world i was talking
about people in the church
right expel the wicked from among you
hand him over to satan so that god would
deal you know so that hopefully he comes
back he says the world god's going to
deal with the world you don't worry
about judging the world you judge those
inside the church the issue with
christianity and i'm not sure if you how
much you would agree with this is we've
done the opposite yeah we've held the
non-christians to the standards of
scripture
and then when pastors when leaders when
people in the church
misbehave abuse act immorally cheat lie
lust of the eyes lest of the flesh pride
of life want to be celebrities for jesus
then
we look the other way and we don't judge
them so we ha we have it backwards on in
a lot of ways and so
the standard is the standard however
if someone's not
wanting to live that standard if
somebody's not a follower of jesus
what business is it of mine to judge
them now if they ask me i'm going to
proclaim the gospel i'm going to tell
them hey man like god created us to be
image bearers of god that is good news
sin enters the picture we screw it up it
doesn't take a a a rocket scientist to
look around the world and say there's
some evil stuff i got some some issues
with me
and according to jesus standard you look
at a woman lustfully committed adultery
you hate your brother you've committed
murder you'll give an account for every
unwholesome word that's came out of your
mouth the bar is set so high that it's
not about behavior modification it's not
about do do do and keep these rules it's
about whether me you any of us
we don't rise up to the standard
god is too holy and too good so what
does god do god being a good loving god
sends jesus to live the life we couldn't
live to die to death we should have died
on the cross rises on the third day and
that creates a new pathway and that is
the good news right so it's not about
like i'm more morally superior if i told
you all my dirty laundry and all the
stuff i've been through i'm a scumbag
man like it's but but for the grace of
god but for the grace of god there go i
right like so it's it's not a moral uh
superiority complex it's saying man
we're all jacked up but i placed my
faith in jesus and when i placed my
faith in jesus something supernatural
happened
all of a sudden the things i used to
love porn sexual immorality hooking up
with girls in high school
i felt very conflicted and convicted
about those things and all the things i
used to hate church reading the bible
right being around christians who i used
to hate being around christians all of a
sudden i started being drawn to those
things something supernaturally happened
in my heart i think that is the good
news and so i think what happens is
though that's never really fully
articulated and then we go on and we're
projecting something and a lot of times
it is that we struggle with something so
we projected on the world and the world
is like dude i didn't i didn't sign up
to follow your jesus yeah you know and i
and i do believe that faith in jesus
leads to ultimate flourishing i do
believe that is the best way to live um
not as like a prosperity gospel but as
in like your heart will be changed and
you will you will enjoy more contentment
enjoy so i do believe that so
with regards to this my question would
be honestly is there uh like is there an
exit strategy one is there a certain
dollar amount you're hoping to hit and
then two um
do you see yourself doing this
indefinitely and could this be
redirected in a more i don't know
educational route right like if you and
your husband like yo we have this
popping sex life we built this only fast
thing check this out now we're gonna
give you guys some game maybe we won't
be on camera but we'll do a youtube
channel and we'll provide value in terms
of how this is you know hey like do you
keep a schedule do you not keep a
schedule dude right like there was a lot
of things that like me and my wife just
didn't know and like we got around more
married couples and i was like no no you
have to keep a schedule i'm like yes
scheduled good books
it's all the books it's literally on my
calendar
right so and so that i would say like
when is their next strategy is their
dollar amount sorry i'm going on a team
no you're great uh is there is there
like an exit strategy it's like man five
million or is there some point where
like okay i'm just when i'm
50 when i'm a grandma when i'm because
your kids are gonna have kids within the
next decade or so right and then three
like could this be redirected in a way
where maybe you're not on camera
you know but it's but it's but it is
still providing i guess some form of
value in terms of an educational
component yeah absolutely i mean it's
not something i want to do for a long
time and the great thing is i don't i
hate to even say that i want to do
because i don't have to do you know it's
not like obviously we've made enough
money now where i could probably stop
working forever
but i definitely like
building you know another business and
moving into that avenue these are all in
preparation there's a lot of things that
i have in the works and pipeline that
are preparing me for becoming something
i'd like to take like just the i think
about like my core
um what value that i have outside of
just great videos you know so the things
about me that i think can be of value to
people not just in this industry but in
general i mean i have i have come with a
lot of experience in a lot of different
areas of life and um you know i'm also a
veteran too i've dealt with that i went
through a lot of stuff when i was in
military as well and i have a lot of
childhood trauma a lot of stuff and so i
think there's more to my story that of
course the media will never absolutely
you know what i mean that i know could
be of a huge benefit that has led me to
where i am today so to answer that
question yes there's an extra strategy
um that is the goal it's not something i
intend to do forever so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire sauce
cast click right here
[Music]